alright so hi everyone I'm Jeremy again
and i work at mail gun and I do a lot of
writing and go and one of my biggest my
cloak closer thanks testing how's that
better okay cool yeah so I read a lot of
go code at mail gun and one of my
biggest frustrations with go thus far
has been the lack of a really nice
debugger when go first came out of years
ago and I tried it out this was also a
thing but I was like it's kind of a new
language a deberia liminal come along
eventually and then it didn't so I
decided to write my own so an outline of
what I'm going to talk about first I
want to present you the tool go to bug
itself which i think is cool you all
should try and i also want to talk about
some of the tech behind it which
involves a lot of code generation and go
has a lot of good tools for doing this
and especially with go generate now
there are lots of interesting ways to
use code generation so hopefully this
will be a sort of a peak of things that
you can try doing yourself for un
projects and if we'll have time to get
to it I want to talk a little bit about
using supporting concurrency which is
often a hard problem for debuggers but
which is solved in go debug so let's
start with some motivation often code
does not do what we expect so here's a
simple hello world that probably has
some surprising behavior so figure out
what's going on in some cases it's
pretty straightforward look at the code
there's some silly little trick somebody
over road bumped to be a local variable
that does some completely different
behavior great case handled here's
another example I'm sure you've seen the
occasional function here there that has
some logic at the beginning like we have
a loop or we have
so I'm kind of thing and then we expect
to return here and then just to end the
function to keep the compiler happy we
say panic impossible and then you run it
and the panic actually happens and
you're like okay what's going on so in
that case you can use another standard
tool in the program or suite which is
the print statement very high tech and
you can get the valleys of these things
at runtime you can see that our second
thing here is false so that we know that
we need to start looking into this
function for what violate our
expectations but these are pretty simple
examples and real-world code can be a
lot more complicated so here's one
commits that I pulled from male guns
commit history it touches whopping six
thousand lines and there's at least one
bug in this commit so where should I
start asking print which I start
inserting print statements I wonder this
will be like quite a pain to track down
if I don't have a good tool for it but
that's why people wrote debuggers right
so you have GD b which is a standard
well-developed debugger as lots of
people used it and it's not a good fit
for go in fact if you go to this golang
website under dock / gdb they talk about
how gdb is not a good fit for go but you
can try using it anyway so I try to use
it anyway
alright so here's an example program I
wrote just for the demonstration go or
gdb has a tough time with concurrency so
I'm going to give an example of
concurrency here we're just going to
kick off 50 go routines and then we're
going to print them all out and if I
just run it we've got 50 numbers pretty
straightforward so let's see what
happens when you run it in gdb so first
we need to build the thing except we
can't just build it because gdb doesn't
understand some things about building a
straightforward way so we pass it some
extra flags to give it a better chance
oh yeah how's that okay great i'll try
to keep towards the top things okay so
now let's debug it good start
we can see the program we can set a
breakpoint and we can run it and it
stops the breakpoint all right good so
far so let's try printing this variable
end to see what the value is that
doesn't work and as a constant and for
some reason gtb doesn't understand
constants that's fine I don't need to
look at all my constants already know
them let's step into the loop so i can
put the variable I that's great yeah
question oh sorry sorry let's do this
way drag to the right good all right so
i can prove available I perfect that's
its actual value you let the next line
it can print the variable next that's
its actual value looking great all right
now I'm going to step over the print
statement and this is complicated we're
going to print 0 and then go to the next
iteration of the loop except no this is
the most common failure mode for GD
beyond go programs and if you try it
yourself you're probably going to hit
this all over the place I tried to do a
lot of things to get past this you can
try compiling your program in different
versions of go and sometimes that'll
work you can look up different obscure
flags you can try doing all kinds of
things mess of your environment but
you'll often get stuff like this so
let's try something else so now i'm
going to debug the same program using
goody bug and the two differences from
debugging out with gdb first I don't
need the binary file go to bug works
entirely on the source code and second
oh actually I already made this change
it'll point out to you I need to add the
set trace line if you've used pdb the
python debugger before and this probably
looks familiar so whatever i want a
break point I just insert this line into
the source code so now I run it with
good ebook run and the same thing we're
in the program we can print constants
we can put local variables we can again
print next all right and drumroll we can
step over this line and stop thank you
it seems simple but this is such a
victory after struggling with GDB and
then finally we can just intentionally
run the rest of the program all right so
let's talk a little bit about how good a
buck works so first as I mentioned it
works on the source code level we don't
inspect the running binary we don't use
low-level operating system details
instead what go debug does is it takes a
target program source code and it
transforms it into new source code that
implements a debugger for the target
program and this works it supports
concurrent programs and it's completely
portable because it's all go source code
so to explain the idea of how this works
I want to take a very simple example
just to show you know there's nothing up
my sleeves this one does work as you
expect so this is going to be the target
program that we want a debug and by
debug here i'm going to say we want to
stop before we execute this line so
what's going on and then continue in the
users ready so here's a program that
implements exactly that behavior it's
pretty simple change all we do is we add
a print statement and we scan standard
in waiting for and enter key and just to
show you how it works there you go we're
inside the program we stopped before we
ran this print statement we're waiting
for user input and when I'm ready to go
on I can run the rest of the program so
that's all it takes and notice also that
this is a very straightforward
mechanical change so we added a couple
of import statements we added we can
just hard code this line and just put
that directly and the most difficult
thing here is we have to quote right
here we have to quote the line that we
want to print out
and that's that's all there is so that
means that we can automate this so now I
want to talk about automating code
generation and go so to do that oh you
have a question what do you mean read it
yes I can that's so the question was can
you capture the variables in the context
and actually i'll show you quickly how
we do that so I earlier ran this this
program and running it through goody bug
I can just show you the source code that
it generates okay here we go so this is
the source code that it generates and
though that we get access to the
variables is we actually pass them to a
library function so here it for example
immediately after I declared the
constant n I passed it to this library
function called constant and give it the
name of the value and also the variable
itself and then four variables that can
change the value we just passed by
pointer and that's all it takes not
interesting thing here is that we have
nested scopes so we like keep track of
where we are in the scope higher okay
and stuff like that but good question
okay so source code generation I want to
transform the top program into the
bottom program we're going to omit some
of the stuff like scopes and set trace
and stuff like that and just talk about
the mechanical change of going from the
first one the second one so again the
ghost standard library has almost
everything that you need to do this
yourself and anything that's not there
is probably in the go tools of
repository so for example pressing a
file you just import go / parser
and there's one function call will do
everything you need to press a single
file you have this sort of magic token
called the file set that you don't need
to worry much about and then use pass
the file name and you get the syntax
tree out here and then you can whack it
using HT walk and make any
transformations to it that you like so
let's give an example of said
transformation so this the code snippets
here will be inside the function they
pass to st dot walk the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to look
at the type of the note that we get
connolly this is done inside a switch
statement so you switch on the type of
the node and then do different things
for different types but we'll just keep
it simple we're going to say anything
that's not a function declaration we're
just going to ignore so returning nil is
the walks walk api's way of saying stop
the walk here or continue on with
whoever my ancestors were and from there
but don't go any further down in the
tree and then when we dig a function
declaration we're going to loop over all
of its statements and another one we're
going to insert this thing so this is a
compound literal that is the abstract
syntax tree notation for the go debug
that line call it's not a bit verbose
it's the good bug library actually has
some functions that make it so you don't
have to write out this whole thing every
time but it's a pretty simple so what we
have is just a few nested structs and
also this new ident which returns you
another struct and you can see the the
syntax tree here in the struct so we
start with an expression statement
because God about that line is a
function call it's an expression and it
can just analytics as an expression but
if you if you ever done online is a
statement that it needs to be wrapped
and something that's a statement because
expressions are not in general
statements so we wrap it as we call it
an expression statement and then this is
syntax for saying that we're calling
the one relevant field and the
co-expression here is what function
we're calling and then we just say work
on good about deadlines and when we run
this we insert the good budget line
calls that's almost everything that we
were trying to do in the original
transformation so we've inserted go
debug that line before hello one before
if true and before hello three but
notice that there's not one before hello
to and the reason for that is that how
to you is not a direct descendant of the
function declaration dead it's a
descendant of the if statement node and
because we told the walker that we want
to stop if it's not a function
declaration as soon as we got to the if
statement we quit and we didn't insert
the stuff here so that's I'm not going
to modify this to show what it would be
to handle the if statement case but
that's just an example of thinking about
things in terms of syntax trees and how
am i doing for time was it ok cool let's
talk about concurrency so as mentioned
concurrency was one of the things that
really kills GT be running on GoPro on
go programs so how we handle it in goody
bug so first let's take an example
concurrent program so we have a function
foo which has some print statements and
we call it once in the mango routine and
once in another girl routine and the to
go routines run run concurrently and we
wait for the other guillotine to finish
before we exit so when we run it we just
get here some code printed twice so what
can go wrong when we try to debug this
so here's the straightforward thing of
doing what I did in the last example to
this example we just call good about
that line everywhere and let's see what
happens with that
and I made a note co routines to ok so
we've stopped at the starting off the
new girl routine and things look good so
far then as soon as we step so once we
do the step we're going to kick off a
second girl routine will have two things
running at once and we immediately get
some kind of weird behavior here so we
get to goody bug prompts move it up
again how's that great no I don't have
flex running ok so we have to go to bug
prompts and we also see this thing we're
about to enter function food twice
because those go routines are just doing
the goat goody bug code and the output
looks a little weird alright so now
we've stepped into one of them now it's
hanging now something happened now
they're fighting over reading standard
in any way it doesn't work so how can we
fix that well if we knew what the
current girl routine was when we called
good ebook that line then we could make
sure that we only followed one and if we
got any other girl routine calling the
same code we would check its identify or
see that's not the one that we care
about and have it move along so can we
identify a goroutine there's talked
about a lot on going nuts as
thread-local storage or is go local
storage go routine local storage people
want it for logging for example if you
want to follow a single girl routine as
it traces through whatever execution and
see that in your logs but the official
answer is it's not going to be added to
the runtime anytime soon but fortunately
there's this wonderful
little library called GLS or go routine
local storage that solves the problem
for you and I want to talk about the
trick that I use this because it's
pretty neat so the girl one time gives
you access to the stack you can see who
called you and you get like an int or
something that corresponds to the
function for every function above you so
what you can do is you can designate
special functions as being as having
some kind of meaning as being a tag and
then you can call them in a certain
order to write out whatever information
you want on to the stack which you can
the later reread anywhere further down
the stack to get back the Guru teen
identifier anyway it's pretty neat it's
cute you should check out the library I
think it's very well done I especially
recommend to read the readme and it
works so using this library we can get
access to the guillotine ID and once we
do that it's pretty straightforward to
implement concurrency support you just
do that little check i showed you
earlier I'd so wrapping up a generation
is awesome if you haven't tried it out I
recommend playing with it for one thing
you can implement an entire debugger in
it which I maybe wouldn't have guessed
ahead of time without knowing anything
about little up with details and you
have lots of great support from the go
tool train and go generate is cool too
you should try go debug there are some
known problems with it to know ahead of
time before digging into it but if you
encounter any broken edge cases I would
love to hear about them so that I can
fix them so I can make it much more
awesome Oh in particularly if you want
to run the go debug run syntax that I
was using you have to check out the
working branch right now it's going to
be merged soon but if I yeah and that's
all I have thank you very much
yeah question
yeah so repeating the question he's
asking for clarification on what we're
doing here so we parse the st and we add
some code oh what's that doing so yes if
we add our an interpreter it's not
really that basically all I still
running everything so you like we
compile it to a binary and run the
binary but it's just using the ghost in
a tool chain so the example I gave of
well i can let me show you I'll just
explain it so good but line call that I
inserted what it does now with like the
full concurrency support and everything
else is it checks mi the guillotine that
is being followed by the debugger if not
keep running visit a bugger in step or
next line mode if not keep running if
I'm still here then output a prompt and
wait for user input and so this is just
a function call and you could insert
these function calls and she run code by
hand if you wanted to so goody bug just
automates inserting these I hope that
answers question right
I'm it yeah it's not an interpreter and
also the AFT knowledge goes away once i
have outputted the source code and then
it's just a regular go program can you
set break points on the fly right now no
but it's something that I plan to add in
the future yeah so the question is can i
insert all this debugging stuff only in
the places that I want to look at the
answer is yes in fact that's the default
behavior whatever package you run it on
you'll just insert debugging stuff into
that package and then everything else
will run as normal yeah so the question
is have I seen any instances of my
generated code interfering with the
original code I have generated code that
doesn't compile for various reasons one
was like naively quoting strings by just
like putting a quote mark before and
after it which breaks when I'm quoting a
string mostly spend still the edge cases
like that you could have saw insert
variables and those could conflict with
variables that are already to find in
the program but one of the things that I
do in one of my passes down the ASG I
keep track of any names that might
conflict with the names that I know I'm
going to generate and then I generate
different names
okay so the question was about delve
which is another debugger for go so the
answer to why I wrote my own debugger in
the first place was I didn't find out
about Dalton till after writing to the
bugger
yeah so if you have a timeout like your
code is timing up some function call and
the function call now has is waiting for
user input what's going to happen there
yeah it's going to the what about
sharing the time it out is going to time
it out and I don't know that's not a
case that I've tried to handle yet what
it called cogeneration is more like code
transformation yeah basically I'm
translating a target program into its
dip debugger program yeah do I support
stepping into functions that are
imported so by default I just instrument
the current package and so if you step
if you call a function from another
package then it'll just run without
being debugged if you want to debug it
um just recently I added you can pass a
flag that will say which packages you
want to generate debugging code for this
doesn't yet work for the standard
library because the standard library is
imported in a slightly different way but
for any other third-party code you can
do that
yeah so what can I do besides Grady bug
run single file name so this interface
definitely needs to work the goal is to
implement go debug run go debug build
and go to big test and handle all the
arguments correctly but those have just
been implemented very recently and that
it doesn't deal very well with arguments
the most general thing you can do is run
ktbug dash X and that'll I don't know i
call it dash x but it will print out
over your original source files and you
can just like change directory directory
changing all the stuff you want and then
build the whole thing but yet the goal
is to have a much nicer go run test
build API last question
right question is China working on
really simple programs I've actually
used it in the world where things are
more interesting where we had like
multiple processes and all kind of stuff
going on it has had a little testing in
that environment so far it's been a mole
I have run it a little bit on my own
packages but I'm sure that there are
edge cases that need to be fixed